- I am Leah Chase, chef and co-owner
of Dooky Chase's Restaurant.
I'm 94 years old.
I been in this kitchen 71 years.
Every day I come in this kitchen.
7:30 in the morning, I hit this floor,
and I don't leave until we close.
When guests come to this city,
they know when they come here
they're gonna a good bowl of creole gumbo,
they're gonna get some jambalaya,
they're gonna get some good fried chicken,
they're gonna get what I serve.
The butter just melts
in there and gives it
all kinds of good flavor.
Every day, I meet new people,
and they come to taste the food I cook.
That makes you feel good.
This place, back in the
day, was a landmark.
We became a meeting place in
the Civil Rights Movement,
and so you had always Thurgood
Marshall, Ernest Wright,
all the NAACP people.
Black people knew they
could come to Dooky Chase's
and would not be disturbed by anybody.
It was illegal for whites
and blacks to be together,
but they came here.
This was the safe haven for all of us.
I fed Mr. Obama.
He was gonna eat the gumbo,
and he gets a hot sauce bottle.
Oh my god.
I said, "Mr. Obama, you don't
put hot sauce in my gumbo".
Now, that gets around
all the neighborhood,
and so they said, "You
told him good, Ms. Dooky.
"Don't be messing up your gumbo". (laughs)
I was recognized by James Beard
with the Lifetime Achievement Award.
To me, that was unbelievable.
Sometimes I said, "I
don't know how I got here,
"but it gives you energy to keep going,"
and my whole thing is to
make this restaurant go.
I wanna be one of the
best restaurants there is.